Maris, the three-year-old, said, "So, is
Phil in heaven?" And I said, "Yep." So,
we're happy. I said, "Yep." David said,
"Yep." She said, "So, why are people
sad?" "Because we're not going to see
him for a while." "Well, will he will he
come back?" And I said, "Yep, that does
sound nice, but I want to know the
truth. There has been some sad news.
Phil Robertson has passed away at age 79
and heartbroken and sad for the family.
I watched the movie about his life
called the blind. It was so inspiring.
What an amazing testimony. Very
important topic. When people pass away,
we start to think about things. What
happens when you die? Is there a heaven?
Is there a hell? Is there something
else? When the serpent was in the
garden, the first lie ever spoken to a
human was, "You shall never die." The
Bible doesn't ever contradict itself. Do
we believe that?